(upbeat music)
- My name is Brandie.
- May name is Sawyer.
- My name is Blake
and I'm five.
- My name is Blair and
I'm five. (laughing)
- No, Blair is two!
(upbeat music)
- My Mom looks like a 19 year old.
- Three and about.
- [Unison] 25!
- [Woman] Adults are five years old?
- Or 27, or 28 or 29 or 30.
- And her brother looks
like a 16 year old.
- 31, 32,
33, 34, 45.
- My youngest Grandma
is 55 I believe.
- 49
- [Woman] Oh, you're still counting.
- 100!
- Oh, right here.
- Right there.
- Hey Brandi, I'm Jared,
nice to meet you.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you.
I like your socks.
- It's nice to meet you. (laughing)
- Yep, yep!
Yep.
- Pshst!
- Oh, that was fancy.
(upbeat music)
- How old are you?
- You gotta guess for yourself.
- Tell me how old are
you and then you go back.
- 38.
- 38 okay I'll take it.
- I think you're supposed to guess.
- No.
- No, I'm not guessing.
- It's too hard?
- 39.
(upbeat music)
- Why do you think I look 39?
- I don't know.
- You guys want to know
how old I really am?
- No, no no.
- I'm 32.
You were close.
- I'm really 18.
- So, let's guess again.
- So how old do you think I am now.
- 18!
- Ah.
- I'm 25.
- Ah hum.
- Okay.
- I'm actually about to turn 39,
how did you know?
- Random guess.
- My real age is 25.
- You go back and we'll
tell you how old you are.
- Would you have guessed that I'm 25?
- There you have it.
- Oh, Blair and Blake,
how old am I?
- Five!
- 25!
- 25 , good job.
- High five.
You didn't say 50,
I was worried about 50.
Time flies when you're having fun.
- I know.
One day you're two,
next time you're 32.
- I guess I need to be
using better foundation.
I got clocked by a kid. (laughing)
- You're supposed to say
'cause I'm so pretty.
- Really. (laughing)
(upbeat music)